Persian leopards are among the largest
cats in the world that once ranged all
the way from Turkey to Afghanistan but
habitat loss poaching and a decimated
prey base has made the Persian leopard
one of the rarest big cats on earth take
your light up and take it around to this
outside door and we'll just side like
this cat okay I mean it would be a lot
more effective yeah I need more home
from the coaly tip me more juice
[Music]
the cat sick cats don't need no
exertions almost over with knocking down
the tooth
[Music]
oh man that's nice that is nice
nice good good
what a good cat I couldn't have asked
for a better shoot right yep you outside
I still doing up in this one okay I'm
ready okay good
couch ultimate I got five thousand and
it looked fantastic
[Music]
Oh